hello everybody and welcome to part 5 of
let's play penumbra overture where we
last left off I had spent a little bit
more time on a puzzle than I wanted to
but that's ok what's in here
open up oh yeah oh using my muscles oh
yeah nothing that was a useful waste of
my time
you too oh nothing
ok alright not about way o power room
that seems important get open
Oh shaky-shaky chick get also alien I
want if that's it
illusion a big fancy word that means the
meaning of something else that metaphor
no I don't know shut up don't judge me I
know what I'm talking about
yep that seems about right the big hole
Oh wonder what's down there a ladder ok
ok go there just yet power generator ooh
big switch let me pull it chunk ah thank
you so much ok
alright down the ladder ooh this is a
box of rocks
Oh generator spare part batteries sounds
important oh yeah shut up you should
fuzzy show fuzzy up
uh-huh all right let's look this looks
important avoid wear and tear grease
industrial workplace electrical
insulation can be expensive to install
and maintain so the economical 7g basic
model arrives without a much much more
oh okay all right clear of equipment
connects all right valve cooling system
HR and I'm not gonna memorize any of
that so just keep it in my notebook I
keep everything else important all right
probably one of the things I shouldn't
mess with down the hole not down the
hole that's ridiculous
don't be so silly all right it's a big
shaft
oh all right everybody um I'll shut up
no time for your whispers oh why did I
go down here for no reason
I just saw a big hole and I left right
into it Oh cuz it joke there - boring
boring something jumping out of me oh
nothing oh that would have been a great
opportunity to scare me huh not that I
can be scared oh this looks boring how
battery very look at it eyeballs oh I
know I know oh so smart I get this box
open so either I throw it down the shaft
moving these things Oh get out of my way
oh yeah get down that hole get in there
oh I'm so smart
haha yeah that wouldn't damage the
batteries at all let me just break these
other things like Boop boink
pow all right BAM fine
[ __ ] get my way oh yeah oh ho all right
I get it
something didn't jump out of me because
is waiting to me actually for me to
actually do something
oh thanks for insulting my intelligence
monster but now I'm ready for you
right there it is give me that any
mother anymore
nope all right Oh Oh wonder what's gonna
be at the top of this ladder oh it's a
big mystery maybe please don't be
something huh ah okay ah again a wasted
opportunity frictional games not right
battery come on up come all right good
chunk all right we should be all set
let me look at my notebooks feel
positively paper no wrong there we go
all right job of clear equipment
connected confirmed secondary flow
secondary flows secondary flow what is
this letter I okay oh it's coded now
right symbol for water there's two of
them could be alright fluid control all
right I'm gonna guess it's this double
water oh so smart
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
turn on cooling system all right let's
see I was worn out huh uh
uh I bet this one is it yeah oh let me
check make sure it's probably smarter
hexxus team behind Greece oh that's
probably the one main valve primary flow
number one pull me now I love to pull
the lever um cooling system oh no I bet
the waters of cooling system
ah let me turn this off ah screw screw
you I'm gonna turn on Moll on digit this
I'm not even gonna wait well I don't
care about porter they're just all going
on baby yeah bring it on bring on the
power yep yep yep yeah all yeah here's a
where's that lift lever
come here lever I got a date with
destiny yep
that was good fuse box [ __ ] is this yeah
fuse fuse
fuse fuse box
booze booze Suzie Feazell oh I'm smarter
than this I'm smarter than this
maybe I didn't do it in the right order
nope it's gone okay all right okay feet
ah ah ha fuse boxes in here I'm probably
wrong again like I happen every other
time bow flammable
all right that's why I went okay what do
we got here ah ha ha why do you keep
looking at things John that you don't
care about oh okay I'm okay
open up yeah right emergency procedures
blah blah blah ensure the stability of
surrounding Avella tapping and feel oh
yeah feel the rock once you feel certain
that there are no risks of a rockslide
yeah Kochi furnace is unavailable a
family tapping out a message on the wall
of the cave okay yeah uh good day that
sounds good I like that punk punk punk
anybody hear me
uh only the monsters are those dumb of
me I probably just alerted all the
monsters ah contents of the box of
course thanks boy why would things be in
the box batteries I'm such a good
Explorer find things everywhere beef
jerky
jerky yeah yeah opera coming up broom my
best friend you're my only friend
what do we got here something in here
huh oh yeah nothing nothing
yar
oh boy that's a lot of words piss
camaraderie
however penrose examine Eddie Jones
husband lead mine Foreman radio ok
anybody on the radio
uh-huh anybody oh ah yeah hello I really
don't like it oh I love it you should
shut up John yeah whatever
down you freakin African no reason it up
recently of course recently there's some
in here but they just happen to be
monstery oh great oh shut up I don't
care
oh yeah someone responding in my tapping
on the walls pink boot aah bonk all
right that's enough of that
Oh what do we got here what do we got
here we got here what what aah
oh dear who's there I got a pickaxe
don't mess with me a good hiding place
Wow Wow y ou learnt too far that's a
doggy
haha doggy you trapped yeah shut up Doug
Oh power I gotta turn on the power uh
how do I turn on the power
I don't know I'm so dumb I'm so dumb
ah ah ha ha uh-huh get open bomb bay
Emma oh come on
ok
oh I'm so not smart I'm not smart right
now oh all right fine I'll figure this
out actually I'll figure this out later
because I have to pause it right here
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you in part 6 of penumbra overture
bye bye